viele leute denken dass man nur im
frühling einmal sein gemüse aussieht und
danach überhaupt nicht mehr aber wenn
man das ganze jahr über aus seinem
garten ernten möchte dann muss man auch
das ganze jahr über auswählen und der
juli ist ein richtig wichtiger monat für
ganz viele wichtige aussagen damit man
im herbst und winter dann immer noch aus
dem garten essen kann und welche gemüse
man jetzt aussehen kann im haus im beet
und welche man auch nach draußen
pflanzen kann das zeige ich euch in
diesem video und schaut mal wie viele
samentütchen hier allein bei der anzucht
im haus lügen ich mache jetzt draußen
weil die pflänzchen jetzt wunderbar auch
im gewächshaus vorgezogen werden können
wir können das aber genauso gut auch im
haus machen mittlerweile geht das auch
gut auf der fensterbank weil die tage
jetzt so lange sind das die pflänzchen
da auch richtig schön licht bekommen
wir fangen an mit dem kohlrabi da habe
ich jetzt eine andere sorte als sonst
ihr wisst ja ich bin sonst eigentlich
eher so ein super schmelz band jetzt
wäre ich aber die sorte lanrue aus und
zwar weil die relativ forsthart ist und
der juli kohlrabi den wir jetzt aussehen
der bleibt ja oft noch bis in den herbst
hinein im beet stehen und dann ist es
ganz praktisch wenn man dem nicht sofort
ernten muss bei den ersten frösten und
hier sehe ich jetzt wie bei vielen
anderen gemüsen auch ganz viele samen in
einem töpfchen bedeckte die bei
kohlgemüse sind immer so ein zentimeter
erde die man drüber machen sein
und dann spiele ich die später in
einzelne töpfchen sobald sie die ersten
laubblätter gebildet haben
es gibt ordentlich kohlrabi für den
herbst und winter sie habe ich wieder
meine kohle ball brause
da haben ja so viele von euch
nachgefragt deswegen verlinkt ich dir
euch mal gerne in der video beschreibung
bei der fabi nämlich gerade eine
lieferung bekommen hat und weiter geht's
mit dem chinakohl china co ich recht
dass nur falsch aus
da bei euch zwei sorten an einmal eine
sehr späte sorte die aber auch jetzt in
die erde kommt sollte die sorte quito
und dann die sorte granat das ist die
andere ein bisschen verwirrend weil es
gibt auch ein rot gold der granat heißt
normalerweise doppeln sich die
sortennamen ja nicht so bei den teufel
kämpft
chinakohl falls ihr das noch nicht
ausprobiert habe mach das mal generell
habt ihr lust auf dementiere videos weil
langsam wird es ja zeit
kärnten wieder mehr im garten und da
kann ich gerne auch mal ein hippie video
für euch machen wenn ihr lust habt oder
schreibt mir einfach gerne mal was für
haltbar machen themen euch interessieren
was für rezepte ihr gerne sehen wollte
auf dem kanal viele fragen immer wie ich
das mache wenn ich so viel kohl anbauer
das ist ja immer mit der fruchtfolge
nicht ganz einfach
ich packe einfach meine kohle biete
immer richtig voll das heißt sobald
irgendwo zum beispiel rotkohl abgeerntet
ist kommt dann der blumenkohl hinterher
und rosenkohl sehe ich jetzt auch das
ist so ziemlich die letzte gelegenheit
den noch zu sehen denkt dran jetzt ist
nämlich die zeit um die wintergemüse
auszusehen wie zum beispiel den
rosenkohl und wenn man das verbot dann
hat man im winter kein eigenes
gartengemüse das heißt jetzt mache ich
noch mal einen späteren einsatz sind
schon ein paar rosenkohl pflänzchen in
meinen bieten aber die sind dann
irgendwann abgeerntet und dann werde ich
den hier essen und da brauche ich jetzt
die sorte krone an hatten wir auch schon
ein paar mal im garten die hat uns auch
sehr überzeugt als nächstes kommt der
radicchio da habe ich zwei verschiedene
so hatten einmal castelfranco fannys ich
weiß nicht ob ich das richtig
ausgesprochen habe und wahre egarter die
luisa die sollte habe ich schon mal
angebaut und die fand ich richtig gut
ich find sie generell wunderschön
ich finde man kann ich den ganzen tag
allerersten wir ziemlich bitter aber ab
und zu ist das richtig tolle im winter
dann den salat damit aufzupeppen und
außerdem sehen die einfach wunderschön
aber dass die sind beide weiß mit roten
sprenkeln und ja das wird richtig schön
aus linien im herbst nicht zu dick mit
erde bedecken
als nächstes kommt eine bunte salat
palette in die anzucht da sehe ich jetzt
einfach ganz viele unterschiedliche
sorten aus man muss im juli dann auch
gar nicht mehr so arg darauf achten das
ist eine chance fest sollte ist dann wer
einen letzten videos immer mal darüber
gesprochen dass das im sommer ein
bisschen das problem ist dass die salate
immer ganz schnell blühen wollen aber
jetzt sind sie langsam wieder ein
bisschen frei und können einfach
aussehen worauf wir lust haben das jetzt
einmal ein salat der die sorte heißt
mythos die ich jetzt hier aus der dann
ein eichblattsalat die sorte heißt
die ruft sind stehen immer einfach eine
bunte mischung wie zu haben gerade was
salat angeht salat ist auch ein licht
käme also nur obenauf streu sind und
dann an drücken
ich habe die erde hat schon feuer
angefeuchtet und dann reicht es wenn man
die einfach gut an drückt so dass die
lahmen richtig schön mit der erde
verbunden sind aber nicht von ihr
bedeckt werden
das ist das schöne augsburger augsburger
von dem habe ich gerade auch noch ein
exemplar im gewächshaus und das ist der
grösste salat den ich hier angebaut habe
es vielleicht nochmal zeigen und ich
habe euch auch mal erzählt dass ich ein
gemüse überhaupt nicht hinkriege
anzubauen und das ist der fenchel egal
was ich mache es klappt einfach nicht
ich habe jetzt im frühling schon mal ein
paar versuche gestartet
es sieht okay aus aber sie sind nicht
besonders groß und dann haben aber auch
viele von euch geschrieben dass man die
lieber jetzt aussehen soll und in
richtung herbst ernten weil das
einfacher funktioniert als wenn man ihn
so früh im jahr aussieht wie ich das
probiert habe und deswegen testen wir
jetzt einfach mal wenn ich hier so
hatten hier einmal die sorte finow dass
auch ein schönes bild drauf da haben
auch viele von euch geschrieben dass das
eine tolle sorte ist nur gucken es hat
auch ganz viele geschrieben dass bei
ihnen gar kein problem wenn ich an zu
bauen ich weiß echt nicht was wir haben
die beiden die breite sollte heißt
perfektion das hört sich doch gut an
oder da kann doch nicht viel schiefgehen
wehrt euch dann berichten wie es läuft
was meine erste ernte habe oder auch
nicht und dann sehe ich jetzt auch
hinter hecken zwiebeln
das ist ein ganz tolles wintergemüse das
sind die lauchzwiebeln aber die sind
mehrjährig und man kann sie den ganzen
winter über ernten die kommen jedes jahr
wieder das ist super praktisch und ich
will mir davon immer im garten haben
deswegen kommen die jetzt auch in
gelehrt
davon mache ich gleich drei teams weiter
interessiert welche seite ich andere das
ist die sorte fremden aber ich glaube da
gibt es auch ganz so viele
unterschiedliche und dann machen wir
gleich weiter mit den pflanzen die man
jetzt direkt in viel sehen kann
bevor ich jetzt mit dem freiland
aussaaten anfang ist immer ein ganz
guter tipp wenn ihr eure seite schon
gezogen habt dass ihr die energie ist
bevor die samen in die erde kommen so
dass die eimer schon schön feucht ist da
fangen wir mal mit dem mangold an den
kann man jetzt einfach direkt in speed
sind da hab ich jetzt eine weiße sorte
ansonsten bei euch ganz gerne sondern
sorten mix an der heißt rainbow von dem
ist mir nur das saatgut ausgegangen
deswegen ist jetzt eine andere sorte her
und natürlich kommt jetzt auch wieder
ein bus bodensatz in die erde
das ist ganz wichtig dass und
buschbohnen immer wieder auslädt damit
man dann auch ganz lange was von ihnen
hat und ich sage jetzt die sorte cupido
man spricht man das source die macht auf
jeden fall faden lose lösen das finde
ich immer ganz wichtig weil wenn man die
in rauen mengen geerntet und dann immer
noch bei jeder bohne den faden absitzen
muss dann ist das ziemlich nervig die
sind ertragreich gut eine sehr schöne
sorte und vor allem sehen die samen
unglaublich schön aus schaut euch die
man bei spinat könnt ihr jetzt auch
sehen ich selbst wieder die sorte gamma
sohn aus weil das eine sorte ist die im
sommer nicht so schnell schießt von
richtung spätsommer und herbst hin könnt
ihr dann auch wieder die ganz normalen
spieler sollten aussehen und radieschen
könnt ihr jetzt auch aussehen da sehe
ich ganz gern die sorte sora aus oder
zucker da bin ich mir nicht so ganz
sicher wenn man die ausspricht war wenn
ihr zum beispiel eine lücke haben
zwischen euren kohlköpfen dann könnt ihr
da ein paradies den samen in die erde
streuseln die gehen auf und schließen
die lücke und habt ihr da super schnell
noch eine kleine ernte genau so könnt
ihr jetzt auch rettich aussehen und
rucola rucola-salat wenn ihr den einmal
an bord gerade wenn ihr wilden rucola an
bord der auch finde ich ein bisschen
lecker schmeckt als der kultur rucola
dann kann er sich auch immer wieder
selber aussehen und bleibt quasi für
immer in euren garten es ich sehe jetzt
ihr überhaupt keinen rucola mehr der
kommt jedes jahr von selber und wenn ihr
noch keine starken boden gewählt habt
oder vielleicht an euren stangen so ein
paar lücken sind wohl nicht alle boden
aufgegangen sind dann könnt ihr jetzt
immer noch stangenbohnen sehen dass es
kein problem ist allerdings im juli
jetzt auch die letzte chance damit man
dann bevor im herbst noch eine gute
ernte bekommt und sprechen wir über die
ihr gemüse die man jetzt nach draußen
pflanzen kann also wenn ihr entweder
pflänzchen auf dem markt gekauft habt
oder
im haus selber vorgezogen habt dann
könnt ihr jetzt alle kohlgemüse die wir
euch noch oben stehen in die erde
bringen egal ob kohlrabi weiß kohl
blumenkohl brokkoli was gibt es noch
rotkohl kann jetzt auch in die erde
wirsing und rosenkohl die klassischen
wintergemüse ist jetzt ganz wichtig dass
man an die denkt und die können jetzt
alle nach draußen ins beet gepflanzt
werden denkt aber immer daran dass sie
alle gemüse die ihrem haus vor gezogen
habt erstmal eine woche langsam ans
sonnenlicht gewöhnt und die ab härte zu
nennt man das damit die nicht sofort
einen sonnenbrand bekommen wenn man die
nach draußen fleiß und salat kann man
jetzt auch ins freiland pflanzen wie
fasst rund ums jahr
ich mache das jetzt so dass ich meine
salat pflänzchen hier um eine zucchini
pflanze herum pflanze seht ihr dass die
wachsen alle hier sozusagen im kreis um
die große zucchini pflanze rum weil die
dem platz jetzt noch nicht für sich
selber braucht irgendwann ist die so
groß dass sie hier alles beschatten
würde aber bis dahin habe ich meine
salaten abgeerntet und so kann ich den
platz der jetzt sonst frei wäre noch
richtig schön nutzen das klappt auch mit
anderen schnell wachsenden gemüsen wie
zum beispiel radies und wenn ihr noch
eine zucchini pflanze bei euch zu hause
rum stehen habt oder noch eine auf dem
wochenmarkt bekommt dann könnt ihr jetzt
auch noch nach draußen ins beet pflanzen
genauso wie laut pflänzchen die kann man
jetzt auch noch wunderbar pflanzen vor
allem den lauf den mann dann im winter
erntet ein gemüse über das wir heute
überhaupt nicht gesprochen haben weil
die schon lange in der erde sind ist ja
die tomate und welche pflege arbeiten
bei den tomaten gerade super wichtig
sind damit die pflanzen gesund bleiben
und man am ende eine dicke fette ernte
hat das zeige ich euch da trieben
ansonsten geht raus macht die welt ein
bisschen grüner und wir sehen uns
nächsten samstag wieder um 10 uhr neues
video